hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 9 video merry
Christmas to everyone
the writers went way above and beyond
the call putting in as many Easter eggs
as possible really big easter eggs and
we had a really awesome cameo from the
original flash story so I'll explain
everything so just careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet but starting with top five moments
number five the reverse flash has been
back for a while I just loved that Cisco
tried to call him the opposite flash
greatest almost name ever maybe just
because the reverse flash is such a big
character Joe said it to Eddie but the
man in yellow as they call him for most
of the episode had been searching for
something for weeks
really that mercury labs tachyon
generator I think that in combination
with the STAR Labs treadmill will be the
stand-in for the cosmic treadmill he
also directly challenged Barry which is
a little bit different from the
professor zoom character in the comic
books he was just a little bit more evil
the hunter so lamont zoom was the one
that was pushing the flash to be better
in his own really perverted twisted way
at some point all the reverse flashes go
a little bit nuts if you were a little
bit confused about what was happening
when they were fighting in the stadium
there were lights flashing around them
while they were standing still in front
of the camera it just implies that there
are two versions of their characters in
that time and space like the older
versions of themselves or from another
time in place chasing each other around
just like they were around Barry's
mother's murder time is a weird thing
they have yet to explain how they're
gonna treat it in the time causality
loop previously I thought that there was
more than one version of the reverse
flash that we would see on screen and as
we saw during the episode when they
captured the reverse flash in the
Tachyon generator and he pulled harrison
wells in and started beating on him
there really were two of them like that
wasn't him punching himself the real
question is what is his next move and
how often he's he going to appear in the
back half of the season number four the
Barry iris Eddie ship turns into a
full-blown triangle most people don't
like the romancey part of the episodes
but this is really important for the
flash rebirth storyline if you have read
the comic books and you know what
happens to hunters o Lamont's character
I do feel like Eddie Thawne is hunter
zolomon just with a different name
they're just simplifying things a little
bit and making him part of the Thawne
lineage
I think in order to drive a rift between
their three characters by the end of the
season they started berry on the path
you know telling iris I love you we've
seen a little bit of tension building
Eddie starting to pick up what Barry's
doing I think they're just gonna build
and build to the end of the season when
they have a big blowout hunter zolomon
and Wally West I mean it was a different
flash in the comics but they're just you
know like I said simplifying things they
were good friends before they had their
big falling-out and he went on to become
the you know really notable character he
does in the comics just trying to avoid
rampant spoilers for people that haven't
read the comics I will say it's not the
most exciting part of the episode but I
did love the fact that Barry gave her a
ring so many flash ring references in
this episode if the key that Eddie had
given iris had also been another ring
outages lost my it would've been so
hilarious at various points in the
comics the flash ring has just served as
a containment unit for Barry's in the
flash of suits the different flashes
professor zoom also has one too as we've
seen though Grant Gustin does not have a
flash ring or he has not gotten his yet
it's possible that they could do
something different with the show and
they could make the ring just a key
which actually paints a nice metaphor
with the gifts that Eddie and Barry gave
to Iris the ring is a key see how that
works out I think that also implies that
iris is going to be a point of
contention coming up to the finale
she'll be a focal point for the Flash's
battle with the reverse-flash which is
also something from the comics so this
is why you need to read the comics it's
all in there it's all in flash rebirth
number three Tina McGee
Amanda pays cameo so if you didn't
recognize her Tina McGee was Amanda
paise the actress who also starred in
the original flash show with John Wesley
Shipp they've been really good about
bringing actors from the original show
back they just cast Mark Hamill as the
trickster on the show he'll play an
older version of his character but he
also played the trickster on the classic
series he and John Wesley Shipp were
actually talking to each other on
Twitter it was really funny Jedi Master
come in to Central City true to form
they give dr. McGee this really awesome
backstory she's working at mercury labs
as in max mercury also one of the
speedsters part of the flash family that
is that's a nice Easter Egg I don't
think that that's going to go anywhere I
think they gave the competing lab that
name as an homage I don't think we're
going to see max mercury although it is
possible we could see someone from his
family to be honest really anything is
possible
arrow has stretched limits with what
it's
from the comics the flash has just blown
right through that with superpowers so
we could totally see a lot of other
members of the flash family they've
already confirmed that wally west is
going to be a thing but not for a while
not for a long time number two firestorm
is back and kicking ass I think I
mentioned into my last video but when he
fought off the reverse flash that's what
his powers are gonna look like I'm sure
I'll have a totally tricked-out STAR
Labs costume that looks a little bit
like it does in the comics if grant
gustin's flash suit is any indication
they'll probably just make it a little
more subtle but as Harrison wells said
on his life they will bring Ronnie back
which sounds so much more awesome given
the post-credits scene it just makes it
sound so much more sinister there's also
the caitlin side of this too
it sets up she's willing to break her
morals you know Bend any rule for Ronnie
like that's how much she cares about him
so I'm really interested to see if she
betrays the group at some point for
Ronnie or to try and save Ronnie from
something given the new dynamic with
Harrison wells now it gets a lot more
confusing but think about it this way
Caitlin snow is so much more
unpredictable now that she knows that
Ronnie is alive it has this really
awesome layer of complexity to danielle
Panabaker character so i think she's
gonna have a lot more fun playing
caitlin snow in the back half of the
season if there's anything that the
flash has done really well it's make
really amazing complex characters
nothing is more frustrating than seeing
a character that's stuck in the living
room so to speak you know like Barry
said I've been stuck in that living room
ever since he killed my mother
just as a side tangent if all that talk
about him visiting all those places
around the earth is any indication he's
probably going to do that like in
between seasons he's probably gonna run
around and visit places back to robbie
amell though so yeah he is totally
messed up in his head as far as we know
the only people inside there are dr.
Martin Stein and Ronnie Raymond's
character they've also cast Jason Rusch
and they referred to something as the
firestorm program something that Martin
Stein was working on I don't know how
the jason rusch character is going to
work with Martin Stein and Ronnie
Raymond I don't know if they're all
three going to be in there at the same
time or not I mean we'll find out the
next time we see him we will see them
again within the first couple episodes
of the back half of the season but
really excited to see Robbie Amell in
the show he hasn't turned into much of a
character so far like he hasn't had much
of a chance to stretch his acting
muscles so just wait till he gets some
more scenes and gets to turn into a real
character right right now he
more of a light show so to speak I know
a lot of tomorrow people are really
excited to see him back especially now
that he can totally cameo on arrow and
my number one moment of course Harrison
wells
post credit scene a lot of you were
asking me questions on Twitter about
what it means with the flash ring and
the reverse flash suit and the Tachyon
generator so here's what I think is
going on Harrison wells is an older
version of Professor zoom like it's the
same person but we're just seeing them
at different points in their timeline so
the reverse flash that gets caught in
the Tachyon generator is just a younger
version that has started the time-travel
loop he's trying to effect history with
the Tachyon generator which is why
Harrison wells
Jack's it onto his suit but in order to
make all those things possible he has to
preserve the timeline in a certain way
so that means that Grant Gustin has to
become the flash so that he can become
professor zoom someday
that's why wells killed Simon Stagg he
wants to protect Barry Allen so he can
grow up and do something presumably that
leads to professor zoom or al Barth on
however you want to think about him
getting his powers this is where I think
we could possibly get into hunter
zolomon territory because it's possible
that Eddie Thawne is the father of
Harrison wells or at least one of his
progenitors Harrison wells seems like
he's from way way in the future but
based on the timeline in the newspaper
it's a little hard to tell how far in
advance he is he could be Eddie Thawne
son or he could be his grandson or his
great-great-great great-great grandson
they will answer that by the end of the
season the only part where it really
does get confusing is is if Harrison
wells is the older version of the
character of the AO bar Thawne character
why does he need to go back in the loop
if the younger one already did it in my
head I'm thinking about it as like a
recursive time loop so we can work it
out in bonus videos as we move forward
I'm sure they'll give us more
information about it they're pretty good
about explaining things on the show let
me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and do you think
Harrison wells is like a child or a
great great great grandchild of Eddie
Thawne there are a couple possibilities
he could be a descendent of Grant Gustin
he has the flash ring but a Bart Thawne
also had a flash ring of all the
theories that turned out to not be true
I love the idea that Gideon might be a
version of Skeets and there might be
some sort of Booster Gold Easter egg in
there
clearly that has been proven to not be
true but I still like the idea it is
possible we could see Booster Gold at
some point some really important moments
that we need to remember though Eddie
Thawne knows about metahumans probably
gonna find out that Barry is the flash
they probably will develop a friendship
and then something crazy will happen
with that love triangle that'll blow it
up in their faces it's possible they
could push a hunter zolomon storyline
for him into season two I don't think
that they'll wait that long they've done
a pretty good job of just delivering
things like gorilla grodd for instance
they didn't waste any time and rolling
that out so a lot of things happening
really quickly the Rogues are coming
back in the next episode though that's
basally with the teasers for the next
episode rogues revenge which is also a
comic book storyline if you want to
learn all about it just read rogues
revenge
it's a Geoff Johns story totally awesome
I think that took place during Final
Crisis I already mentioned most of the
Easter eggs but just one more about max
mercury when Harrison wells said that
they were rivals of us the rival was one
of the first reverse flashes max mercury
ended up taking him out but also ended
up dying in doing so the rival ended up
taking his persona and this before so
just kind of disappearing into
nothingness or disappearing to the Speed
Force itself so just nice references to
the rival the original reverse flash and
Max mercury the other Easter Egg is
flashpoint although time travel is a big
part of flash rebirth which is a
completely different storyline that
involves Barry's mother flashpoint is
also a time travel story where Barry
accidentally changes things and it goes
really really badly they turned it into
an animated movie so you can totally
check it out it just called Justice
League flashpoint it's possible that
they could turn that into like a season
2 thing they could push things into a
flashpoint territory which also involves
professor zoom the professor zoom
version of the reverse-flash it's like a
very Tony Stark situation where the hero
ends up causing the problem and then has
to fix it himself there was also the
gift that Barry gave - Harrison wells
wrapped in a very blue looking wrapping
paper I just thought a bit is cobalt
blue wrapping paper cobalt blue was
another reverse flash that was part of
the Thawne lineage but was actually a
blood relative of Barry Allen it gets
timey wimey
like he ended up getting raised by
thawne's but genetically he was related
to Barry Allen overall I gave the
episode a solid a it was an amazing end
to an amazing first half of the season
of all the new comic book shows we've
been getting this season the flat
I feel has been the home run everything
else is being judged by the benchmark
that it set it is a little unfair just
because the team from arrow the creative
team is the one that developed the flash
and because arrow is one of the most
successful if not the most successful
comic book show in recent memory it just
stands the reason that anything else
that they would do would also be just as
awesome that doesn't mean that it's all
perfect but it means that their head and
shoulders beyond like what David Goyer
and a lot of the other studios are doing
there are a whole lot of new comic book
shows coming I'm optimistic about some
of them cautiously optimistic about the
rest I am kind of worried about the
Krypton one one of the things I think
this episode did really well though was
deliver really big moments that were
tied to really big character arcs like
it wasn't just a big reveal they just
rolled out like they'd been developing
Ronnie Raymond as a character as this
idea and Caitlin's had for a long time
so when we see the emotion on her face
it actually feels real and then the
payoff is just so much bigger when he
rolls in like the cavalry to help Barry
Allen true he's not much of a character
yet but that'll come in time I think my
favorite Grant Gustin moment was the
scene he had with John Wesley Shipp the
man in yellow has taken enough from us
do not let him take anymore so glad that
they gave the original flash or the
original TV flash that great moment they
really do take care of their stars I'd
say of all the characters that I'm most
excited about it's really the Eddie
Thawne character they really waited a
while to start using him I think it was
almost like the first four episodes
before we saw him get some real moments
I mean now we understand why I mean
they're just slowly teasing this Thawne
lineage out with the reverse-flash so
excited to find out which direction
they're going like I said though I mean
generally just take flash rebirth as the
baseline they're gonna modify things a
little bit they'll mix a match with new
52 elements but generally flash rebirth
is the homework that you need to do if
you want to learn about in the comics
arrow did this really awesome thing with
the female characters with the secondary
female characters like Laurel and Thea
this season that I'm hoping that it does
with Candace Patton's character in the
second half of the season the only
reason I haven't been a huge fan of her
just because she hasn't had the chance
to get some real pathos I mean yeah
she's a blogger she works at the coffee
shop now that the love triangle is
turning into a thing I think we'll get
some more interesting drama arrow is
also kind of playing with the idea of
the love triangle as long as they don't
lean on it too hard I think it'll be
interesting it's mostly the Eddie
very relationship that I think we'll be
watching iris is just like the wheel
around which they turn and I just can't
say enough about Tom Cavanagh he's just
like the most amazing character on this
show I think I said in one of my older
videos you know the only reason that
actors like him who actually can lead
their own shows take smaller roles like
this is because they turn into much
bigger roles which obviously totally
just happened and in the process he is
also using his spare time to create
genetically enhanced gorillas of all the
antagonists in this new season of comic
book TV he is definitely the most fun to
watch so just some great sentimental
character moments mixed in with some
huge action set pieces and WTF reveals
firestorm going to be so much awesome
reverse-flash can't wait to see more of
him especially with the Tachyon
generator faster-than-light travel
remember that's time travel right there
so do not forget big stuff happening
tomorrow arrow Rochelle ghoul so if you
haven't read that Batman comic that I
keep talking about it's the very first
story to feature racial goal in a Batman
comic so just read up on that I think
it's number 232 so I will post that
video tomorrow I'll try to post a bonus
video just for Rachele goal tomorrow too
be sure to subscribe to get it so in the
meantime new mobile links up here at the
top in case you guys are watching on
your mobile phone or your tablet it's
the same as the link side over here but
click here to learn all about the
reverse-flash in the comics like the
history of the reverse lash and click
here to get ready for arrow tomorrow
thank you so much for watching so let's
all flash shrink this bump each other
into tomorrow's episode
you